the british public are fed up
fed up with a prime minister who
promises big but never delivers
fed up with a prime minister who's
presided over a culture of lies and law
breaking at the heart of government
fed up with a prime minister who is
utterly unfit for the great office that
he holds
conservative mps
made their choice tonight
they have ignored the british public
and hitched themselves and their party
firmly to boris johnson and everything
that he represents
the conservative party now believes that
good government focused on improving
lives is too much to ask
the conservative government
now believes that breaking the law is no
impediment to making the law
the conservative party now believes that
the british public have no right to
expect honest politicians
over the weekend
the whole country celebrated the queen's
platinum jubilee it was a tribute
to 70 years of humility decency and
respect
a reminder of our common cause to build
a better country for ourselves our
children and our grandchildren
it is grotesque
that the very next day
the conservative party has chosen to
throw that sense of duty and those
values on the bonfire
the choice in british politics
is clearer tonight
than ever before
a labour party united under my
leadership with a plan to ensure that
britain is never again plunged into a
cost of living crisis
focused on growing the economy so we can
afford world-class schools and hospitals
and determined to restore trust in
politics
or a conservative party that is divided
propping up boris johnson with no plan
to tackle the issues
facing you
and your family
i don't claim that i or my party will
get everything right but i promise that
when we don't
we will always be honest with you
we will prioritize your prosperity and
your security
and we will treat you with the respect
you deserve from your politicians
i promise that together we will end the
fast we've seen in recent months
that we will once again put the country
first get rid of this tired out of touch
government
and get britain back on track
thank you